when you think about the creation of
money you think about places like this
or this but what if money was created
here in a Brooklyn loft by a group of
young entrepreneurs and data nerds the
company is called air swap the founders
all met at either Burning Man or
Business School and they envision appear
to peer cryptocurrency exchange today
they're launching their ICO or initial
coin offering in ICO is sort of like an
IPO but instead of buying shares
investors bike tokens this process is
entirely crypto so you cannot use for
example a fiat currency like a dollar to
purchase our tokens so we're selling our
tokens for ether which is effectively a
digital currency
most people buy tokens in the hopes that
they'll increase in value much like
shares of a company because this is a
global sale we need to be available to
people in different time zones so the
sale is gonna run for 24 hours and by
the end we will have approximately 35
million dollars what will they do with
all that money well to understand this
you need to know a little bit about
blockchain now let me keep this really
simple a blockchain is a virtual public
ledger that keeps any in every exchange
watertight and protected from fraud or
hacking experts agree the blockchain is
poised to revolutionize the way we do
business in the future using this
groundbreaking technology air swap is
building an exchange that removes all
middlemen lawyers clearing houses banks
and even governments will be bypassed
with this new peer-to-peer system
the same way the internet and
telecommunications allowed for
peer-to-peer information transfer
you're seeing this now happened with
blockchain where you have peer-to-peer
value transfer I think one of the
reasons why people are looking at this
is really started in 2008 when people's
confidence in the financial system was
really shaken to the core and all these
intermediaries that people trusted fell
short and people are looking for an
alternative in which you and I can
exchange value without the need of
depending on these institutions that we
used to trust the demand for this
decentralized exchange is high something
err swap capitalized on by using social
media to build a worldwide online
community in anticipation of their ico
this is basically a live world map of
all the orders that we have coming
through the system updates live and yeah
they're very excited so they're posting
we're probably around 23 million right
now I can actually check yeah we're at
23 million the 24 hour long token sale
wasn't without its hitches several
well-designed fake accounts tried to
scam members of the air swap community
out of their ether but this is a
phishing scam
right now I'm crafting an announcement
to alert the community to several what
are actually very well done websites
that are trying to convince people that
they are us
so we need to like actively expose them
the imposters were eventually shut down
in sales resumed uninterrupted
throughout the night and into the next
morning right now we have just around 13
minutes left until the sell is over it's
been a very tough 24 hours we've sold
out our entire allocation by the end of
the ico and swap had raised what is now
valued at over fifty million dollars of
ether issuing all of their available
tokens worldwide by most if not all
measures I can call it a success but the
playing field is flooded with I SEOs
right now in 2016 there were fewer than
50 icos in 2017 that number jumped to
over 250 now everyone from overstock.com
to kodak yes kodak has jumped onto the
cryptocurrency bandwagon and launched
their own icos no one knows who will
survive the hype an air swap remains a
relative newcomer but they remain
optimistic that their global community
of thousands of token holders will push
them to dominance all from this Brooklyn
loft and in the bleary landscape of
cryptocurrency that's worth something
morning how awake
[Music]
you